ebay
elz
4 millionen bei 117
1419 mit diesem ebay fail und zwar
verkaufte jemand dvds von der film serie
heroes er schreibt allerdings in den
titel der anzeige herpel
dvd serien 1 bis 4 und beherrschen
schwer zu erkennen
sein beim nächsten ebay versuchte liebe
ute eine zwei bis drei zimmer
mietwohnung in berlin und eine person
antwortet ihm auf diese suchanfrage mit
es gibt in berlin keine freien wohnungen
mehr 1000 aufrufe zeichen vergisst diese
suche hier denn berlin ist voll und
erstickt an suchenden hey gute danke für
die info die suche daraufhin beendet
übergröße
beim nächsten ebay feld wird wieder
etwas gesucht und zwar eine bmw
e46 also ein auto und ein anbieter
schickten daraufhin ein foto von seinem
bmw e46 daraufhin schreibt die suchen
allerdings guten tag das auto ist mir
leider zu groß
und freundlichen grüßen kann ich
verstehen wenn sie eine 46 suchen dass
ihnen meine 46 zu groß ist es macht halt
wirklich keinen sinn
da so wie wenn ich sage ja ich suchen
fußball ihren fußball nähe der ist mir
zu billig irgendwie in die verkauft eine
person aus houston in texas ein sofa und
er schreibt ganz klar da die
beschreibung ein moped also keine
haustiere waren da drauf und halt blöd
wenn man gerade auf dem foto was du rein
stellt eine katze auf dem sofa sitzt ja
der ist heute allerdings der ebay fans
mit luca tag wo leute irgendwie nur was
suchen auf ebay wie beispielsweise hier
da wird nämlich einen schrott metall
elektro fahrrad was maschinen kupfer
gesucht man denkt dann vielleicht ein
fahrradfahrer verrate rein geschrieben
hat er macht als foto allerdings dass
hier rein
ford pulli machen wir jedoch weiter mit
einem 47 zoll fernseher verkauft wird
und ein interessent fragt den verkäufer
wie groß ist denn der fernseher wir
haben eine schrankwand und da steht
momentan ein 42 zoll fern sondern es ist
schon etwas knapp der verkäufer
antwortet darauf 106 x 70 cm
ich habe leider keinen meterstab hier
könnten sie das anders aus messen womit
haben sie normale bierflaschen und
könnten die man aneinander legen die
breite nur bügelflaschen eine cola
flaschen auch nicht havana club
gorbatschow oder fett die flasche
eventuell den standard tv habe ich
perfekt wie viele verwies ist der
fernseher breit
das ist dann leider zu breit danke für
die mir ich hätte dir allein dafür schon
geld berechnet hallo ich hätte interesse
an der quatsch der coach comic alter was
ist dass diese scheiß autokorrektur ich
hätte interesse an dem sofa so fühle ich
mich jedes mal wenn ich eine nachricht
von sandra bekomme hier verkauft jemand
für 50 euro schneemann hände
im guten zustand
browser sind stark an
ich biete 60 euro ich verkaufe neue
fußballschuhe verpackt nike er die
sehen wirklich super verpackt aus da auf
dem foto machen wir jedoch weiter mit
einem ebay fällt der genau meinen dummen
humor match da fragt nämlich eine person
hat sind die möbel aus holz oder ist das
sparen liebe grüße hey kann ich die
morgen sagen oder einfach am nächsten
tag sparen man
kann
hahn
mülheim saarn jens spahn
rantanplan
ali khan clan mal die bahn fahren
entweder sagen an das fünfte opfer auf
machen jedoch nur indirekt weiter mit
dem nächsten meerfeld und zwar schreibt
eine person guten tag wie viel kostet
ende preis abholen für 70 euro kannst du
es abholen 60 eur 70 euro dann schreibt
die personen 65 euro also geht schon ein
bisschen höher und der verkäufer stadt
daraufhin 75 euro ok treffen uns in der
mitte 70 euro rechnen um 70 euro okay
das ist so wie wenn dir jemand hat jeder
verstand das muss jetzt nicht mehr klar
hier verkauft jemand ein ikea bett und
das wollte er auch eigentlich in den
titel von dem ebay angebotsschreiben
ikea bett sind allerdings acht
buchstaben und das war zu kurz für den
titel deswegen hat er das 1 1 getippt
und dazu noch geschrieben ikea bett was
für zu kurze titel who
schüre solche sachen sind genau mein
humor uhr wartet dann
[Musik]
das waren eher peinlich sofort sehe ich
ihn im youtube video ausgang auch hier
verkauft jemand einen fahrrad drahtesel
vintage stil wenig gefahren
gegebenenfalls für bastler man denkt
sich dann vielleicht ja kommen da ist
recht wenn ein kratzer irgendwie an
einer felge oder da ist der ständer
klappert ein bisschen na ja
das ist wirklich was für bastler hat
jemand ein ikea kalac regal zu
verschenken und ein interessent fragt
den verkäufer hallo ist da die kommode
hier ist der arme
mann kann etwas nicht sein guten tag
vielen dank für ihre nachricht gerne
helfe ich ihnen weiter leider können wir
ihnen in diesem fall nicht weiter helfen
ist tut mir leid ich hoffe ich konnte
ihnen weiterhelfen und wünschen noch
einen schönen tag ihr serviceteam
den hab ich auch schon bei der
installation
laserdruckers ich dann
meine installation letzter zeit einfach
pur will ich mir wirklich folgen
ganz andere frage wieder bock auf blogs
ich habe generell tempo videos von mir
ohne morgen das bike ab hallo morgen
sieht es schlecht aus könnte erst
nächste woche morgen dann muss ich
leider nein sagen da ich morgen schon
was wichtiges vorhaben und es jetzt so
kurzfristig ist komme trotzdem liegt das
geld hin richtig schlüssel und alles
andere her fahrern gleich heim mit dem
bock was hast du denn so richtiges vor
etwas sehr wichtiges morgen geht
wirklich dich laufen oder was bleibt
daheim ich mache was ich will und wann
ich es will du willst was von mir und
nicht andersrum das ist kein notverkauf
und ich bin ich knapp bei kasse pleite
geier und hat keine zähne tschüss
quickly
englischer hallo habe interesse an dem
huawei bin auf mönchengladbach wäre noch
ein preis was zu machen bzw was ist ihre
schmerzgrenze
dann würde ich wenn wir uns einigen
können heute abholen 500 sind west preis
weil steht vb das heißt behandlungs
basis das heißt west preis
hier verkauft jemand kitzbühel
hausschuhe in der größe 27 und
da ist ein großes loch am großen zeh mit
großer onkel sagt man auch ne
auf dass so ein mann das wie dieser eine
job von beginn wo wir allerdings gerade
schon bei deutschen jobs sind meine
lieben freunde dass sie jetzt die jens
spahn platte
da kann leider wirklich von mir kommen
kommen allerdings auch schon zum letzten
die bfl für heute und zwar diesmal
wieder ein reim nämlich rosen sind rot
englisch wenig später solange benutze
ich einfach mein translator
es war mal wieder klatscht reiches video
heute wenn es euch gefallen hat und las
auch keinen daumen hoch da neben einem
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wir
weiter wie es nicht passen wollte
ich habe
[Musik]